our first guest is a women's rights
campaigner who's photographed during her
arrest became the defining image of the
vigil for sarah everard that c stevenson
joins me now
a warning we're about to show you some
flashing images during the course of the
interview welcome to you good evening
your reaction first of all to the
resignation of cresta dick
i mean of course i'm pleased um
i think a lot of families are as well
families that have dealt with like their
family members dying in police custody
under her reign um all sorts of things
that have happened during her being the
head of the the met um i think what we
need to focus on though as well is that
this not be a token gesture you know
this doesn't fix anything and i just
hope that whoever's in charge next
understands that radical change needs to
be implemented to fix these systemic
issues within the map
what would mean for you and mark it as
not being a token gesture
i mean you know a token gesture at the
moment is saying you know that oh she's
resigned so that fixes the problem um
you know what they really need to do is
fully focus on what has happened um i
know the siddiq khan has said that it's
not a historic um issue but it is a
historic issue i know that he means that
it is current and it is current of
course but it is historic also and we've
not listened to the countless women that
have spoken about police brutality
throughout their lives um and it's only
just come to light recently and and
people need to focus on that and it
needs to be fixed
we're looking at pictures of you at the
sarah varada vigil um how would you
characterize your experience with the
met
well i i never experienced anything like
that before and you know i am a white
woman so i understand my privilege on
that side of things that i've never been
racially profiled um i'm straight
passing so i've never had homophobic
abuse from the police um however these
things happen on a daily occurrence
i've spoken to multiple people who have
actually left the police force because
of these things people aren't shocked
with the the news that's come out and
and now that i i know these things since
the vigil um i have no trust in the
police force whatsoever
is that something that was changed
because of your experience did you have
trust in the police force beforehand i
did before yeah i've never had an issue
with the police before but again that's
because i'm white and from a certain
background and
i just wouldn't be a main target for
police
what was going through your mind when
you were being taken away by police we
saw the shots of you in handcuffs and
that that picture that that many people
now used to to mark the sarah everard
vigil what was going through your mind
um i thought that i would get kicked out
of university i thought i'd never be
able to work again um you know i didn't
expect that to happen like i said i've
never been in trouble with the police
even on a small scale so i had no idea
what was happening um i've said before i
was terrified a lot of people don't
believe me because the way i looked in
those videos but at the time you don't
realize what is going through someone's
head and the processing of that um you
know it was traumatizing i had
nightmares afterwards it was awful
the met claim that they've got a record
number of uh female officers and and
certainly crested dick
claimed that moves were being made to
change the the culture of the the police
force why do you think that in reality
it seems that that nothing has changed
the problem is that a lot of people do
say that if you've hired more women
police officers then that's going to
change things that doesn't change
anything at all women can still have
internalized misogyny they can still be
racist and homophobic and transphobic so
to say that they might hire more police
who are women um you know to have you've
got
who was the head of the police a gay
woman so and and she didn't do a good
job it doesn't matter if you're a woman
or a man if you are internal internally
misogynistic and not
holding accountable the issues that are
going on within your police force it
doesn't matter what gender you are it
doesn't matter what sex you are it
doesn't matter who you are as a person
you need to have those belief systems
that the police are there to protect and
serve the public no matter what
do you believe though that this will
make it more difficult for another woman
to step forward um and take on this role
again i don't think it matters if a
woman or a man steps forward by like
they need to be someone who understands
what is going on systemically within the
police force and i don't know whether
that means that hopefully we have
someone from the outside even it just
needs to be someone who is unbiased and
will not let police officers get away
with this kind of behaviour
do you think that there does now need to
be further investigation into the
culture that has come to the fall that
exists within the police force there
always should have been um you know the
countless um independent investigations
that they've had you've got the police
investigating the police here and things
like this although they will come to
like a few things that they've done
wrong it needs to be ongoing throughout
the whole of the force it's not even
just the met police it's all police um
you know there really needs to be a
proper investigation on how to radically
change the systemic issues
patty thank you so much for speaking to
us uh this evening thank you for sharing
your views with us patsy stevenson there